it's the mother [__] twilight zone
people it's Friday
all your fears will be confirmed
he will hesitate masturbate and his
family so get your [__] together
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with uncle Joey Friday July the 1st
everybody's equal today you understand
me where the rent is due and I don't
feel so good my [__] self but you
know what we still gotta take it to the
hoop on a daily [__] basis and
get off I haven't been [__] are and
what's vitamin ha vitamin [__] a
reefer that's what we got in today we're
smoking a beautiful collection of
herbage today I've got the Paris og one
of the best ways I smoked the last
couple of weeks and as usual this
[__] that [__] poor got rid of
glue number four they use this fire I
made this week they shoot that [__]
girl in Chicago and they [__] spent
all this [__] pubic hairs on this
ship takes it to a different level how
are you good to see you [__]
uncle Joey here today
the birds are [__] singing the sun
shining your dicks clean what else what
else what else wrong they tell you you
got the world by the balls and you sit
there go July weekend am I gonna be like
the rest of the sheep and you know what
once you're [__] 12 unless you
lighten flyaways all the same I don't
want to see my ever gonna stand there
what the [__] is wrong with these jet
down
my house on fire though we have likable
fireworks at your beloved Gentile
buddies Oh [__] drink why I was wrong
with these [__]
what is wrong with these [__]
you know I add a were they wrong with me
I'm ready this treatment my
[__] day was some gorillas
Google when I have listened
even me gorillas whatever the [__] is in
your neighborhoods good enough ain't no
[__] better than you these people
have Elmo's dick they just tie his
gorilla glue but in your neighborhood
it's [__] monkey dick yeah who gives a
[__] what would what training well they
said he's [__] idiot which train are
you smoking if you consider shoot is up
with strainer you smoke discipline debt
that's what like one for this floor
that's why I asked him listen I ain't
got time to be cute
I needed you to get my body numb listen
give me a [__] break all right enough
with the [__] [__] your that's dog
all the rest of these [__] Jericho I
smoke a sativa [__] have yet another
because you want to be jim morrison's
never gonna happen you're a [__]
idiot you could smoke 20 choices of TV
you still be a [__] idiot okay relax
when you smoke dope is to see the [__]
devil that's it everything else is
background [__] music these guys with
background music when you go onto the
deep murky waters that's when this [__]
comes out of it now when you have a body
I write my best jokes I'm sativa
have you considered sucking my dick but
enzyme but enough with the chitty-chat
uncle Joey spark that [__]
without a doubt
frig that subset come to me and talk to
me about [__] Delhi Dahlia let's keep
to the subjects that you know
filled it - that ain't got dick I got a
drill class I got a break up the class I
got a mobility class and I'm smoking
dope the rest of the gang going out
tonight
understand me go mommy beat your [__]
shinebox me I'm gonna smoke reefer till
one of the eyes ball was out of my
[__] eye socket today I understand I'm
a little like Michael Bisping with a
fucked-up eye
let's in that said I did come to you
with a million stories in dramas being
or ain't no drama
it's Friday who gives a [__] you had a
chat you don't get a check you stabbed
up your foot but I [__] a ball on the
arm but what's the joint what's the time
we'll worry about the next weeks of what
until I collect get some [__] bottle
rockets and knock yourself out there
[__] stymie
throwing Heat like a [__] with
this bike this is the old reliable meal
this thing fell to a store isn't it
break are you for you know why cuz it's
cold it would [__] THC and strength
Betsy Ross type [__] that's why but
enough is enough joy was at the
chitty-chat
I score another one what the [__] you
ain't gone no rang and the party
all-star for me to what I got now I
[__] said how do you smoke with your
[__] tear you down I'm on one
because you're hearing thanks
Joey what are you gonna do there's no
gummy bears a lot over 100 milligrams
any ton of them really only thing it's
only a hundred many [__] nine of them
gonna come to me shed a tear like the
[__] Indian the commercial assemblies
we smoked people pissed in the ocean
will make them that's alright nothing
you know but at least I know that don't
it I don't buy a pair glasses and and
talk to other people with glasses and
Tyler I'm smart I'm a political [__]
out which we got from CNN that's very
interesting because the Republicans shut
the [__] up cry yourself to sleep every
night this [__] Natasha what [__]
Joey and his [__] cohorts on Twitter
and the universe gets stoned we don't
give a [__]
Scylla's [__] glasses you know number
30 people it's Friday
you gotta [__] talk a little bit
the Anakim the squirrels want to fall
off the [__] tree it's amazing I wish
I could show you this from
that to fight interest the [__]
no she chases
listen sir happy Canada Day to you
[__] if you don't go join those
Canadians Rock Canadians I got nothing
Canadians is the reason I'm still
[__] alive know why because they're
real [__] people to add some of them
are [__] them but the other half a
[__] solid [__] they got a
ton of Canadian [__] friends Twitter
and likewise I love you [__]
with all my life some cash is [__]
Morris - you know I tell you guys I'm
stoned that sugar happens listen mace to
be able to die - I met you [__]
she understand that be in my room right
now but no you guys Bing uncle Joey
let's smoke some reefer
let's finish this bite
and I'll see you [__] later and
that ice podcast I have no [__]
but guess what I've been taking baths
it's [__] special
and try to get out that's it midday
oh yeah
unless that and this is it
you don't say what do you think
we smoke some reefer we say hello we
look at each other's eyes balls make
sure nobody's [__] fake in the front
and that simply wish ourselves you know
what we got safe keep the eyes open if
you're gonna depart you and I said my
brothers be safe I love you uncle Joey
that your bad boy have been in to get
into my might then I'm all wrong oh yeah
I know what I see
method and I like whenever a big fool
made a wire besides I love your mother
[__] to stay black have a great day
happy 4th of July weekend comes a joy
love should be an American shoot a
[__] watching for long before he
pulls the [__] suicide switch number
captivate a man who [__] storm
youngsaeng between us for nobody else I
love you baby
stay black nickel Joey